[Applaudissements]
je voudrais vous raconter une histoire
qui prend ses racines dans l'inde du 21e
siècle
cette histoire c'est celle d'ali bail un
jeune homme de 21 ans née dans une
famille d'agriculteurs très pauvre d'une
région du nord ouest de l'inde
le good rate qui un jour décide de tout
quitter sa famille ses repères sa vie
difficile mais néanmoins sans risque
pour s'engager dans une aventure
périlleuse
il a entendu dire qu'il existait à des
mois de navigation de chez lui une île
prospère où même les paysans les plus
pauvres étaient heureux un matin de
l'année 1895 il embarque donc à bord
d'un boutre qui est un voilier en bois
et part pour une traversée de plusieurs
mois ou à de nombreuses reprises
il évitera de justesse la mort après un
long voyage
il finit par accosté sur l'île de
madagascar
là il monte un petit commerce
le fait fructifier fonde une famille se
marient à des enfants et parvient même à
faire venir ses frères et soeurs qui
étaient restés en inde
il vit une vie bien pleines d'un riche
et finit par mourir sans avoir jamais pu
remettre les pieds sur sa terre natale
cette histoire c'est celle de mon
arrière arrière grand père bonjour à
tous je m'appelle chams rajabaly je suis
en deuxième année à l'essec et comme
vous l'aurez compris en plus d'être
français je suis d'origine indienne et
je suis né et j'ai grandi à madagascar
l'histoire de mon ancêtre que je viens
de vous raconter
est en quelque sorte l'acte fondateur de
ma famille est comme une espèce de
schéma qui s'est répétée au travers des
générations de ses descendants lorsque
je me suis penché sur la notion de
prendre le large
je me suis rendu compte qu'elles avaient
irrigué de manière assez spectaculaire
toute l'histoire de ma famille pour moi
prendre le large
ça a principalement deux significations
la première littérale qu'ils seraient le
fait de quitter le rivage de prendre la
haute mer la seconde plus figurer
signifierait osé sortir des sentiers
battus prendre des risques comme je
voulais je voulais raconter avec
l'histoire d'ali bail il a pris le large
tant sur le plan littérale que sur le
plan figuré et quand j'ai examiné
l'histoire de différents membres de ma
famille je me suis rendu compte que ils
avaient été nombreux à avoir eu un
schéma qu du même type
mon grand père maternel qui lui est né
sur l'île maurice a lui aussi un jour
décidé de tout quitter et il a traversé
l'océan qui sépare l'île maurice de
madagascar au fond de la cale d'un
bateau lui aussi a pris d'énormes
risques parce qu'il ne savait pas dans
quoi ils s'engagent à mais il était
persuadé qu'il trouverait mieux ailleurs
et le choc et le schéma se répète
puisque mon père dans une période de sa
vie où il était en questionnement
existentiel a habité successivement en
france en nouvelle calédonie sur l'île
de la réunion
avant de se réinstaller à madagascar et
chaque fois il y avait une certaine une
sorte de force qui les anime et qui
était faite de détermination de goût
pour le risque de goût pour l'aventuré
puisque c'est ce dont il s'agit et est
aussi
d'une certaine forme de détachement et
j'ai été assez frappé de constater que
personnellement j'avais d'une certaine
manière reproduit dans une moindre
mesure ce schéma puisque comme vous
l'avez compris je suis né à madagascar
et un jour j'ai décidé de tout quitter
mes amis ma famille mes repères pour
venir m'installer en france pour y
poursuivre mes études
bien entendu j'ai pris moins de risques
que mon ancêtre avant moi alors qu'est
ce que je voulais vous dire par cette
histoire
tout d'abord je trouve que c'est une
histoire assez passionnante et qu'elle
nous permet d'une certaine manière de
comprendre peut-être avec plus de
profondeur
les mouvements migratoires qui ont animé
et continue à animer notre monde et je
voulais tirer un enseignement peut être
un peu plus profond de l'examen de
l'histoire de ma famille c'est le
suivant je pense que nous ne devons pas
avoir peur de nous confronter à notre
passé nous sommes dans une société qui a
tendance à mettre l'accent
un accent très fort sur notre
individualité nous voulons nous
démarquer et nous extraire de nos
traditions de notre héritage
je ne suis pas là pour vous dire que
devait penser comme papa et maman que
vous devez agir comme vos ancêtres ont
agi avant vous non bien entendu
je ne suis pas là pour ça mais ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que nous ne
devrions pas avoir peur de nous
confronter au passé à la tradition parce
que personnellement j'ai eu des
questionnements existentiels assez
profond depuis tout petit sur mon
identité je suis français suis-je indien
sujet malgache suis-je les trois à la
fois où aucun des trois et bien en
comprenant que nombreux avaient été mes
ancêtres sans véritable ancrage dans un
pays
j'ai pu d'une certaine manière
relativiser ce questionnement et
finalement me dire que c'était une force
que d'avoir non seulement une attache
mais plusieurs
alors chers amis j'aimerais vous
recommander quelque chose le week-end
prochain c'est à nouveau un week-end de
trois jours
si vous le passé en famille fait la
chose suivante
discutez avec votre grand mère discutait
avec votre grand oncle avec vos parents
allaient dans le grenier fouiller dans
les archives de votre famille consultez
les albums photos poser des questions
parce que je suis convaincu que vous
apprendrez des choses peut-être sur vous
mais en tout cas c'est certain
vous apprendrez des choses sur votre
famille et il ya toujours du bon à tirer
moi ce que j'ai tiré de cet examen
demain de l'histoire de ma famille c'est
que c'est un projet c'est un projet que
j'aimerais entreprendre d'ici quelques
années
c'est celui de repartir sur les traces
de mon ancêtre et traverser l'océan
indien aussi comme lui à bord d'un
boutre ce sera une aventure
peut-être que benoît me donnera quelques
quelques cours de navigation pour cela
mais une chose est sûre et sur cher ami
le fait d'entreprendre des choses dosé
de prendre des risques ne peut apporter
que du bon alors je vous exhorte à le
faire je vous exhorte à oser et à
prendre le large
merci
[Applaudissements]